Welcome back everyone this is the way there was
brand new mandalorian season 3 trailer footage
that was released so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i will be doing regular videos
for all the season three episodes just like i've
done before remember this is also going to connect
with what's happening on the ahsoka series that's
probably going to jump around in the timeline a
little bit there was also an ahsoka teaser trailer
video that they released at star wars celebration
recently i talked about that during my last
mandalorian season 3 trailer video like what
the footage actually revealed who's in the trailer
so i'll link that below in the description like i
said those episodes will air after the mandalorian
season 3 episodes the mandalorian season 3 is
going to premiere during early february next
year but the brand new footage mostly focuses on
all the mandalorians that they're going to feature
during season 3. all the current mandalorians that
are following bo katan krees because remember
her whole thing is becoming the leader of all
mandalorians sitting on the best car throne so
to speak like make all the game of thrones iron
throne jokes there were separate trailer footage
of mando walking down a hallway that's meant to be
a replica of the main throne room on mandalore
unless they've changed the design it's not the
actual main throne room because i think that dave
fellaini wants to be pretty accurate to what they
were depicted during star wars rebels and we saw
the actual throne room during star wars rebels in
the clone wars it was way bigger than the throne
room that was featured in the mandalorian season
3 trailer so i think that's why the mando scene
is happening on a different planet and it also
features a lot of the mandalorians that are now
part of mando's old covert following the armor
there might be other groups of mandalorians out
there because they kind of teased that they all
went to ground all across the outer rim like there
are many coverts of surviving mandalorians it's
not just these two giant factions but that's the
way they make it seem in the teaser trailer like
there's a bunch of mandalorians that follow
the armor that believe one thing in a bunch
of mandalorians that follow bo-katan that believe
something completely different that was the whole
thing they were hyping up during the book of boba
fett episodes is that the armorer really really
hates bogatan so i think we're building up to a
situation where they're going to force mando to
decide who he's going to support like does he want
to join his old covert again become a mandalorian
because that's another big thing during the
teaser trailer footage too them actually going
back to the wreckage of the mandalore planet
and the actual dome city of mandalore you see
it in the teaser trailer footage it almost looks
like the wreckage of one of the death stars but
it's actually the dome city of mandalore that you
saw during star wars the clone wars in star wars
rebels like the dome has been destroyed it's
completely exposing the city but the footage
starts with the heavy infantryman played by jon
favreau firing his large heavy blaster at the
sky in the middle of a crowd of people on this
sand-based town there's a bunch of different
footage from this particular episode on the
same planet it seems like it's the same planet
where the armor has put her new forge inside
this cave system remember the last time we saw
the heavy infantryman he was fighting mando for
the honor of wielding the darksaber and he lost
there are a bunch of other mandalorians random
townspeople running around behind him as he's
firing at something in the sky because he's
the heavy infantryman all of his weapons are
powerful enough to take out a small ship so that
seems like what he's firing at then there's a
completely different scene of the same group of
people same mandalorians same heavy infantrymen
firing at something else but using their jet
packs in their regular blasters but it's the
same desert landscape it's not tatooine it's
just very similar looking landscape to tatooine
there's two different mandalorians using their
wrist grappling hooks like the ones that you've
seen mando and boba fett use in the past there's
a new scene of mando and grogu in his naboo n1
starfighter looking at the window just passing
by a rock formation mando in the armor left on
good terms last season like even though she said
that you have to do all these things on the planet
mandalore bask in these waters to be considered
a mandalorian again and regain your honor
it's really his relationship with bogotan during
the season three trailer footage that they tease
is deteriorating like his relationship with her
is getting worse because she really wants the dark
saber and she has to fight him in order to get it
but it does seem like a lot of the season will be
him working with groups of mandalorians but there
are a couple new imperial scenes new scenes of
star destroyers like actual star destroyers that
people have during the timeline of the mandalorian
which seems like more of a grand admiral thrawn
teaser so i think they want you to remember that
really it's the empire that's technically the
villain in all this there's a scene of the armor
presenting someone with a new blue mandalorian
helmet is the same blue color that bo katan's
night owls wear but it's not clear if it's just
another random blue colored mandalorian helmet
she's created or if it's connected to the night
owls themselves because it doesn't have any of
the trademark night owl symbols on it during my
other season 3 trailer with a different footage
i talk about her new forge area so like i said
that link is below in the description if you want
to learn about that but it's basically her just
moving her forge and her cover to mandalorians
to a different place and mando visits her on
this new planet there's a new scene of a brand
new imperial character in an office the footage
is so blurry that i can't tell who it is but
the way they show him makes it seem like he's
gonna be a bigger character during season three
there's a new scene of grogu inside the naboo n1
starfighter in the middle of a dogfight with shots
of lighting up the canopy it's connected to the
scene of mando doing some trick piloting against
what seems like some imperials in an asteroid
field anytime you see a dog fight in an asteroid
field you either think of empire strikes back in
that dogfight or you think of attack of the clones
in that asteroid dogfight with obi-wan kenobi
but it seems like there's a couple other scenes
of grogu pushing buttons in the ship them using an
r5 droid in place where grogu would normally sit
with them flying in and out of these asteroids
and trying to take out this secret facility
that's also on another asteroid so it seems like
it's part of some larger mission that they're on
and it does seem like they're bringing back
those funny moments of grogu just loving to press
buttons like from season one with him pressing
buttons when he wasn't supposed to and when he
was banging on the cockpit telling mando to make
the naboo n1 starfighter go faster like he's doing
that himself this time there's a new scene of a
bunch of mandalorians wearing blue armor using
this drop ship method to enter combat like a group
of them are literally being dropped out of a ship
like a couple missiles but they all have jet packs
so they all start flying around the minutes they
drop out of the ship this could be connected
to the scene of the armor creating that blue
mandalorian helmet so they could belong to her
group because there are a lot of fight scenes that
take place on this desert-based planet that looks
kind of like tatooine but probably isn't tatooine
they probably got everyone's notes like we're
going back to tatooine way too many times on
all these star wars series stop going back to
tatooine so much the only other thing about this
group of mandalorians is that all the mandalorians
that are part of bo katan's group the night owls
all wear special blue armor but they all have
special markings that mark them as night owls
there's another scene of the armor attacking a
group inside a crowded room with her best car
hammer the same type of fight scene that you saw
her have at the end of season one so it seems like
she's gonna get a bunch more fight scenes herself
like she's featured much more heavily in season
three than she was in previous seasons even during
the book of boba fett because we haven't got a lot
with her character during mando season 2. it also
seems like this scene of her attacking the group
inside the room is connected to all the other
scenes of the mandos attacking on this particular
sand-based planet like it's part of some larger
mission that they're all pulling off there's a
new scene of mando flying his naboo n1 starfighter
back to navarro i've already talked about what's
happening on navarro in the other season 3 trailer
footage in that other video so like i said link is
below in the description for that there's a couple
other funny scenes here with greif carga he's kind
of taken over the town become the administrator
since the end of the book of boba fett season one
there's a new scene of bo katan eating food with
grogu just seeming like it's totally casual like
she's not on the outs with mando at this point i
think they're kind of playing it both ways like
there's a lot of tension between them because
she wants the dark saber and she's trying to
get the mando to do what she wants him to do but
a lot of his allegiance is still with the armor
who hates bokutan so there's this weird triangle
going on between them there's a random scene of
a bunch of babu frick aliens who are working on
something in a regular shop now it's not actual
babu frick from the rise of skywalker it's just a
bunch of members of his race working on something
there's an unfinished cg shot of mando on a lush
green planet standing near a waterfall the cg
is unfinished so it looks kind of raw but it's a
completely different planet that they've been on
before there's a new shot of a full imperial star
destroyer inside imperial shipyards we haven't
actually seen a full star destroyer on the series
and moff gideon's flagship was just a cruiser
bo katan stole that at the end of season two
like they confiscated it after they captured him
there's actually separate footage of her piloting
that and piloting the ship that they stole during
the mandalorian season 2 remember she's been
stealing moff gideon ships just to bolster her
forces in their bid to retake the planet mandalore
so it just sounds like we'll see scenes with her
flying around on those ships but the whole thing
with the star destroyer is that it seems like it's
a scene connected to the empire and it seems like
it would be more connected to grand admiral thrawn
because moff gideon as far as we know didn't have
any actual full star destroyers i think the idea
is that during season three like maybe at the end
there'll be some kind of tag scene that will tease
grand admiral thrawn or someone will mention him
again during season three because ahsoka mentioned
his name during season two so why wouldn't we
see him but i think grand admiral thrawn will
become an even bigger thing we'll actually see him
on screen at least by the ahsoka series episodes
there's a new scene of grogu leaving a larger
ship's cargo bay floating in his new pod with
the top off so that he can see what's going on
and then there's new footage of them flying over
the wreckage of the dome city the mandalorians on
the mandalore planet just to remind you that like
this is the goal during the season then going back
to the actual planet mandalore that really is like
the big goal of mando during season 3 is regaining
his honor by doing what the armor told them to do
basking in these waters they were supposedly
buried when the empire bombed the planet during
the great purge i don't know how much actual time
we're going to spend on the mandalore planet in
present day though because there's so much footage
on other planets and like i said there's a bunch
of other stuff that they've been teasing like
all the grand admiral thrawn stuff and the whole
plot with dr purging and cloning grogu trying to
create force sensitive clones we'll see what that
actually connects to because the funny thing is if
you're a big fan of star wars legends if you read
a lot of those heir to the empire trilogy books
that timothy's on wrote there was a luke clone
during that there were clones of jedi masters
during that and it seems like the grogu cloning
plot connects more with something towards that
like dave filoni and jon favreau are adapting
a lot of the thrawn trilogy plot points into this
newer mandalorian storyline we'll see what kind
of force sensitive clones we see in future series
because it sounds like it's going to be a little
while before they completely pave that up but i
think because dr pershing seems like a bigger deal
during season 3 we'll get at least enough clues
to know where that's headed in a more concrete way
if you haven't read that classic thrawn trilogy
from back in the 90s it was actually a pretty
fantastic trilogy but some of it isn't canon yet
like mara jade is a big part of that storyline and
she hasn't been brought back into the canon yet
it's just that a lot of the grand admiral thrawn
stuff from that story seems like it's resurfacing
now during the mandalorian season 3 and what's
happening with the ahsoka series i'll do more
videos for the mandalorian season 3 and the ahsoka
series when we get more teaser trailer videos
later this year they're still going to be working
on that stuff for a while comic con is happening
next week too there's going to be a bunch of comic
con trailers marvel has a huge comic con panel
with a bunch of stuff they're bringing like a
black panther 2 trailer and probably a couple
other big teaser trailers too like what if
season 2 and maybe a teaser trailer for the x-men
revival series make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
i'll try to do videos for everything that gets
released but there's going to be a lot of really
cool stuff everyone click here for my video on
the other mandalorian season 3 trailer footage
and click here for my brand new loki season 2
first look video in easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!